senator uh all of this every day
it seems more like a night gallery or
you know
the the broad sterling the scary
programs and you don't know what's gonna
happen next
uh what's your take on uh the stunning
news that goes on day by day
tammy the border crisis just gets worse
every month now we have this report
they've released 50 000 illegal aliens
into the country without so much
as a notice to appear without any
paperwork whatsoever just telling them
to very kindly go to their local
immigration office someday and
turn themselves in as illegal aliens
seeking asylum
but you know tammy even if they got even
if they got those papers uh
the the nearly one million illegal
aliens who have arrived since joe biden
took office are not going to leave this
country under joe biden's watch
they're not going to show up for their
hearings if they show up for their
hearings
and they're denied asylum they're just
going to disappear and if they don't
disappear joe biden is not going to
deport
these illegal aliens so the 1 million
illegal aliens who have already arrived
in this country
are here to stay for as long as joe
biden is president and that's why he's
responsible
for this border crisis it was his
rhetoric during the campaign
and his policies that created this open
border and the word is out among illegal
aliens and human traffickers
and these charities that support them
all you have to do is show up at the
border
say a few magic words about being afraid
of persecution in your country which is
almost
never provable and we'll let you in you
know what's interesting
is that this lac almost a lack of a
conscience in
our federal government from the biden
administration because of the
human atrocities that are occurring the
tragedy overall
by allowing this to occur including with
covet and all the other diseases that we
know
have come across the border but we would
suggest perhaps that
you know the world sees this it's kind
of like a systemic
rot that's happening and you're also
working on as an example with the in the
corporate world
coca-cola and the nature of decisions
that are made
uh when it comes to china and and human
rights abuses
tell us a little bit about that as well
yeah tammy we had a hearing yesterday
that was disgraceful and pathetic one of
the most pathetic hearings i've seen
corporate spokesman coming up whose
corporations sponsor
the genocide winter olympics in beijing
next year
and they wouldn't say a single word that
was negative about the chinese communist
party
coca-cola is particularly appalling
because of course
james quincy their ceo i don't even
think he's an american citizen
they can never confirm that he is or is
not an american citizen so he may be a
foreigner
sticking his nose where it doesn't
belong in georgia's election reform law
when coca-cola is in the business of
selling sugary beverages
they're not in the business of writing
election laws yet they'll go out of
their way
to attack democratically elected
legislators in a state like georgia
yet they won't utter a word about the
kind of the most grotesque
kind of genocide against religious and
ethnic minorities in china
or anything else that would cost them a
single dollar james quincy
and coca-cola should be ashamed of the
pathetic performance they had at that
hearing yesterday
and their disgraceful bootlicking of the
chinese communist party
you know this this seems this this uh
sociopathic in a way this lack of
consideration for the impact
on other people across the board is
shocking i do want to i don't know if
you heard a earlier report we're working
more on this
because i think this is going to be big
is also this revelation
that the biden administration uh used
studies
science that may have been in part false
or even fabricated at certain point
during the line
to legitimize their actions now
with the coveted state against the
american people what do you know about
that and what
what are your thoughts on if if as that
gets i think a bit bigger of a story
yeah well i now understand having heard
those reports today why the cdc has
refused to provide data to the united
states senate in the last few days to
justify
their about face on mask mandates
if it's true that they're using studies
that are not
thorough that are not sufficiently
scientific to reimpose
mass mandates on vaccinated individuals
it'll be a scandal of the first order
but you know these little petty
dictators like tony fauci and rachelle
walenski the head of the cdc
just don't want to give up the power
they've been given over the last year
they want to be able to still boss you
around and tell you exactly what you
can do down to the most minut details of
your life
but that's not going to happen in
arkansas well you know this is the issue
is that if they've wanted to do that so
desperately that they've
arguably if all of this ends up being
true perpetrated
a fraud on the american people a study
that
used a vaccine that's not even available
in the united states or approved
a another a study that was reviewed
after
a peer review that was removed from
legitimacy that it was reversed
effectively
that this is the entire united states
government has all the resources
it sounds like a remarkable choice to
make and we are continuing to look into
that as well
and tammy just remember no one elected
tony fauci or michelle wilinski or any
other bureaucrat
in washington make these decisions they
elected elected officials so the buck
stops with joe biden
advisors advise elected officials decide
that's right
we're not going to let uh biden or any
of the democrats be protected in the
meantime because of the use of someone
like a flip-flopper like
fauci sir thank you very much for being
with me tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it
anywhere else